y
[Música]
ah
levanten la mano todos aquellos que
consideran que el sistema educativo
actual necesita un cambio
wow
el sistema educativo es un sistema
social y como cual
el sistema educativo es un modelo social
más y como tal puede dejar de tener
sentido puede dejar de encajar en el
momento en que estamos viviendo y si
muchos de nosotros consideramos que es
necesario que haber un cambio en el es
porque quizás el sistema educativo
actual no sea vigente
mi paso por la escuela secundaria y por
varias actividades extracurriculares me
permitió tener contacto con chicos de
otras provincias y otros países y eso me
mostró otra cara de la realidad
educativa
por primera vez me plantea
qué está pasando en las instituciones
educativas
por ahí me di cuenta de que muchas veces
vamos a ellas simplemente a rendir
exámenes a probar y ya
pero desde mi punto de vista nos estamos
volviendo algo mucho más importante y el
proceso por el cual aprendemos es el
proceso por el cual conocemos y
entendemos las cosas entonces esto me
lleva a preguntarme hasta qué punto le
estamos dando la importancia que merece
a la educación
somos muchos los que pensamos que la
educación es un potencial de cambio
y tantos en nosotros pensamos que
existir un cambio del sistema educativo
porque ese cambio no existe
cuando ignoramos este hecho nos estamos
olvidando de todas esas grandes ideas
que se están formando en cada aula esas
ideas que van a formar nuestro futuro
desde mi punto de vista si nos olvidamos
de esto lo que nos depara
definitivamente no es muy bueno
en cada aula siempre hay quizás que
están escribiendo cosas
que aprendemos cada vez que vamos en las
aulas por ejemplo siempre aprendemos
conceptos no si yo ustedes les pregunto
cuáles son los colores primarios ustedes
seguramente van a decir azul amarillo y
rojo
pero qué pasa si yo les cuento que el
año pasado en un campamento científico
a través de unos experimentos con
linternas me mostraron que eso no es tan
así para las linternas las cosas
funcionan diferente que en los pigmentos
los colores primarios serían el azul el
rojo y el verde en qué momento nos
cuestionamos esto
en ninguna
siguen los conceptos que aprendemos en
la escuela son muy importantes con el
tiempo me di cuenta de que las cosas más
importantes que aprendí en la escuela
fueron herramientas creativas y de
procesamiento y conocimiento esas
herramientas son las que me permitieron
ir más allá poder potenciar mis ideas
generar proyectos pero
desde mi punto de vista estas
herramientas no están tan contempladas
por el sistema educativo
el año pasado me pasó algo muy curioso
en una competencia tecnología en la que
nos dieron un desafío muy raro
teníamos una pila de basura unos embudos
unas mangueras una cinta aisladora y en
un par de horas teníamos que construir
un escritos copio esos que usan los
médicos todos los días para medir
nuestra frecuencia cardíaca nosotros que
teníamos que construir un par de horas
con cosas que en la vida real no tienen
nada de conexión a ver a quién se le
ocurre combinar una manguera con un
embudo creo
sobre un par de horas para construir un
estetoscopio
esta cosa rara funcionó y me permitió
medir la frecuencia cardiaca de una
persona con una certeza bastante baja
qué pasaría si todos los días nos
encontráramos con este tipo de desafíos
en las escuelas yo no tendríamos que
aplicar los principios de física y de
química de matemáticas esos ejercicios
repetitivos que tenemos todos los días
que tenemos los mismos en las pruebas
podríamos hacer cosas como estas
cuántas vidas mejoran todos los días los
estetoscopios un montón no qué pasaría
si comenzaremos a potenciar esas ideas
que empiecen en el aula podríamos
construir cosas inimaginables
definitivamente
con el tiempo también de que mis
preguntas a los profesores muchas veces
son básicamente la respuesta en ningún
momento surge esto de quiero construir
mis propias respuestas
quizás es porque el sistema educativo
muchas veces nos pide que demostremos el
pescado y en ese momento la forma en la
que llegamos al pescado no importa si
fuera se construye boto caña de pescar
si alguien más la construyó
finalmente quiero ver ese producto
y una prueba muy clave de que eso es así
son por ejemplo los machetes porque a
ver si yo te muestro lo que vos querés
que te muestre ya está no importa cómo
llegue eso los machetes son la prueba
clave de que para sistema educativo no
importa cómo llegamos el conocimiento
entonces
hoy tengo proponerles eso enfocarnos en
las ideas
porque estoy segura de que en cada aula
están surgiendo un montón de ideas que
mueren en ese proceso de dame tu
producto chau
e
necesitamos plantearnos seriamente esto
porque estoy segura de que las ideas que
están vigentes hoy en día en el mundo
surgieron así en un aula
y por eso hoy vengo a reclamar por esas
ideas que murieron el sistema educativo
un sistema educativo en el cual lo único
que se espera de vos como alumno no me
nota y que apruebe es nada más
un sistema educativo en el cual nos
volvíamos a decirle a cada chico que
está sentado en su banco
y esa guía que se tuvo que memorizar
tantas veces el al igual que muchos
llegó que pasaron antes por su lugar
vale mucho menos que todas las ideas que
tiene en su cabeza
también vengo a reclamar estas ideas que
murieron un sistema en el cual nos
olvidamos de decirle a cada alumno que
pueden realizar un cambio en este mundo
nadie nace sabiendo el cambio que puede
hacer
hoy
vengo a proponerles estos enfoquémonos
en las ideas
cuántas veces escuchamos esa frase tan
frecuente y tan injusta que generación
más perdida
me gustaría escuchar un
qué estamos haciendo por esta generación
está naciendo por esta generación
perdida los docentes los padres y los
políticos pero también me gustaría
escuchar del otro lado de nosotros los
jóvenes que estamos haciendo para no
ganarnos esta etiqueta
todo va a cambiar cuando recordemos que
la educación no es una obligación es una
responsabilidad porque ese futuro que
está en peligro cuando nos olvidamos de
todas las ideas que se están formando en
cada aula nos pertenece a todos pero no
solo nos pertenece a todos sino que
también nos lo construimos entre todos
vamos a dejar que tantas ideas que
tienen el potencial de cambiar nuestro
futuro se han muriendo en las jaulas
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
sí
y
[Música]